am mittwoch freut sich
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
über den besuch eines heeres angehörigen
der als erster österreicher im
internationalen judo verband kurz jv in
die welt ethikkommission gewählt worden
ist militär ethiker dr würdigen stx wir
sind unglaublich stolz darauf dass es
gelungen ist erstmal mit doktor rüdiger
steckten angehörigen unseres ressorts an
die so wichtige position als mitglied
des welt ethikkomitees zu bringen aber
wenn die frage lautet wie kommt das
zustande dann wahrscheinlich auch weil
er der richtige mann an dieser stelle
ist und weil es so vieles verbinden das
gibt weil die werte die der
internationale judo verband trägt wenn
wir die hand disziplin denken und vieles
was da auch dazugehört sehr ähnlich sind
mit denen die wir als bundesheer als
verteidigungsressort die moralischen
grundsätze des shooters und die
ethischen grundsätze des turms sind
praktisch gedenkt mit dem moralischen
grundsätzen und den ethischen
grundsätzen des militärs so wie wir es
verstehen respekt disziplin mut und so
weiter natürlich wie erziehung zweiter
und neben all diesen werten spricht noch
ein besonderer wert für den österreicher
österreich ist ja alles land und wir
werden unseren beitrag leisten und das
möglichst seriös und fungiert vor allem
mit fachkenntnissen durchzuführen als
erster österreicher in der welt
ethikkommission im internationalen
skiverband will rüdiger stücks
jedenfalls versuchen neue maßstäbe zu
setzen
ich hoffe dass ich mal sterbe setze ich
habe die ehre und das vergnügen im
österreichischen bundesheer jetzt schon
viele jahrzehnte dienen zu dürfen viele
jahrzehnte schon oben zu dürfen aber vor
allem auch nicht nur die klassischen
prinzipien die klassische moralischen
prinzipien zu üben von
selbstbeherrschung bis zum mut
hoffentlich sondern auch an neue grenzen
zu gehen und die neuen grenzen sind wir
machen es konkret sei 2012 den neuen
agenten technologien
ich nehme als großes beispiel für alle
sportler natürlich für alle fragen der
gegenstrom technologien alle fragen des
jungen enhancement um beim mengen vom
neuen technischen und ethischen fragen
aufmacht